[Music]
who have the creativity in their hearts
and their souls who want to be musicians
who want to be engineers who want to be
producers who want to be part of the
industry on an executive level to step
up pink is clapping back at those
comments made by the Recording Academy
president Neil portnow during the 2018
Grammy Awards post-show press conference
after mostly male artists swept the show
pink tweeted in part women and music
don't need to step up women have been
stepping up since the beginning of time
stepping up and also stepping aside
women owned music this year they've been
killing it and every year before this
Charli XCX also chimed in writing a bout
to step up on to your face women are
making amazing music right now what is
this dude talking about Lord who was
nominated for album of the year but
wasn't asked to perform solo tweeted out
her upcoming tour dates along with this
message if you're debating whether or
not I can murder a stage come see it for
yourself
male artists like Kendrick Lamar and
Bruno Mars collected multiple trophies
while Alessia Cara was the only woman to
win a major award from the Recording
Academy like I would like they dream
about winning a Grammy would they or
even like being
fact that I am here is like really weird
I haven't let haven't processing it it's
very I feel like it's really weird dream
[Music]